I wake up next to this guy and as usual
I don't even know his name
I'm trying to get dressed quickly and
get out of there before he wakes up but
I can't find my underwear I look
everywhere but I just can't find them
and then it hits me
I had left them at another guy's
apartment earlier that night and that's
when I knew I had a problem thanks for
sharing this guy well I noticed a lot of
new faces this evening and I'm so glad
you all came and I want you to know that
this is a safe place to share so if you
want to tell us your story
there'll be no judgment sure I'll go hi
y'all
names Wendell and I am in fact a sex you
will add it I want to know and what
brings you here window well you know my
life sexually speaking it's crazy and I
just want to find one single solitary
person to spend the rest of my life with
just one this one so do you feel like
your addiction is too much to handle
right now
duh I mean it's been crazy y'all with me
the nastier the better I'm a dirty dog
try everything all the fixings tantric
much like sting all the bells and
whistles you name it I've done stiff and
when would you say you hit rock bottom
Wendell when it got slippery outside my
shower on the floor outside my shower
oh I hit rock bottom sexually
Oh from last night last night do you
think that you could tell us what
happened what oh yeah let's see uh it's
just like any other night I had ordered
a large pie pepperoni pineapple cheesy
crust she's a red on the side ah cut to
30 min later pizza parlor sent over a
delicious lady delivery person Body ten
face ten that's my weakness so I invited
her inside opened up the box it was hot
devoured the first slice lickety-split
crust first second sliced didn't stand a
chance
hate the tip of that [ __ ] first washed
it down with a pop then I got nasty with
the cheesy bread my heart started
pounding harder than usual ker-slunk
ker-slunk moved on to the third slice
what about the girl what girl oh the
girl yes she was there too invited her
into my boudoir aka the Stabbin cabin we
disrobed one another I touched her on
her genitalia she touched me I'm a man
Italia and that's when I hit it sexually
of course Upstairs Downstairs all around
the town stairs as you do and by then it
was just another nine and I mean oil
everywhere and sauce all over me sauce
oh yeah that's my word for a jack youlet
anywho I'm so distraught because I feel
vulnerable and I don't know I just feel
like anyone could take advantage of me
right now yeah me one
okay let's see what the blonds have to
say from well thank you Wendell um thank
you for sharing it's actually our time
today
[Applause]
you